Well,
Dr Jordan Peterson,
welcome to Sydney on your Australian
tour.
You're talking to a packed out houses
and the interest is extraordinary and
we've had the opportunity to talk
personally and I can understand why I
want to begin with something that
Churchill wrote in the 19 thirties and
he said this,
one of the signs of a great society,
use the diligence with which it passes
culture from one generation to the next,
when one generation no longer passages
on the things that are dear to it,
its heroes and their stories,
and it's religious faith,
it's in effect saying that past is null
and void.
It's of no value.
He goes onto say,
that leaves young people feeling a lack
of direction than a lack of purpose and
opens them to the dictum of Karl Marx
that are people derived of the history,
uh,
easily persuaded.
Have we stripped down the young people
have purpose and meaning and left them
open to being bullied around whether
there's two things about that that,
that I think are really worth,
worth laying out.
The for the first is an analysis of the
purpose of memory.
Now,
because people think that the purpose of
memory is to remember the past and
that's not the purpose of memory.
The purpose of memory is to extract out
from the past lessons to structure the
future and that that's the purpose of
personal memory.
And so you're done with a memory when
you've extracted out the information
that you can use to guide yourself
properly in the future.
So if you have a traumatic memory,
for example,
that's really obsessing you.
If you analyze that memory to the point
where you figured out how you put
yourself at risk and you can determine
how you might avoid that in the future,
then the emotion associated with that
goes away.
So memories are,
has a very pragmatic function and
cultural memories.
The same thing is that we need to
extract out stories from our past that
structure our future,
and we need that because,
uh,
first of all,
if you don't have a purpose,
let's say,
it isn't,
that your life becomes neutral in a,
in a meaningless sense.
It's that your life becomes
characterized by unbearable suffering
because the baseline condition of life
is something like unbearable suffering.
And what you have to set against that is
a noble and worthwhile purpose,
and hopefully,
hopefully your determination of that
purpose is buttress to some degree by
the wisdom the past because you can't
conjure something like that up on your
own.
And if you provide people with nobility
of purpose,
then they can tolerate the suffering of
existence without becoming entirely
corrupted by it.
And cultures that don't do that,
it isn't even so much that they die.
It's the cultures that don't do that are
dead.
They're done.
They don't have a story anymore and they
don't have a call to adventure and then,
well then everyone suffers stupidly.
As a consequence.
It's a very bad thing.
So Churchill made the same observation
that many of the great psychologists and
philosophers made in the early part of
the 20th century.
It's like,
bring this story forward and propagate
it and make it the most noble possible
story.
And then you motivate people to do,
to transcend themselves,
which they need to do.
So yes,
he's exactly right in his diagnosis,
just to stay with him for a moment.
He's painted as the great defender of
freedom.
It's possible that your country,
Canada,
and certainly my country,
Australia,
would have not continued as free
societies had it not been for that man
courageously standing at a time when so
few did.
He wasn't the inventor of freedom.
Freedom is we understand it and I want
to unpack that a bit.
Something very,
very few people in very few cultures
down through the ages and even today
have ever really experienced.
Oh,
well,
yes,
and partly because we're afraid of it.
I would say.
I mean,
people think of freedom as the ability
to implement your whim and freedom opens
up that as a possibility,
but sustainable freedom,
that isn't what it's about at all.
It's about.
It's primarily about responsibility.
It's about determining which load you're
going to pick up and carry.
That's the proper definition of
appropriate freedom.
It's not grout DM,
gratification of instantaneous impulse.
It's self evident that that doesn't
work.
Two year olds do that and that's why
they can't live in the world.
They can't organize themselves across
time.
They can't sacrifice the moment for the
future and the more sophisticated you
get,
I suppose in some sense the more you're
able to do that and then your freedom
becomes the freedom to choose the proper
responsibility and that's not.
That's also not something that we've
been good at communicating to young
people.
If we talk to them about responsibility,
we don't generally do it in a finger
wagging sort of way and it's like,
well,
you're breaking the rules.
You're a bad person,
and and and well,
that may be true because people break
the rules and there's no shortage of
badness in people,
but the proper message for young people
is to say,
well,
no,
you don't understand you.
You want to take on responsibility.
You want to take on the heaviest load
that you can conceive of,
that you might be able to move because
it gives your life,
nobility and purpose and that offsets
the tragedy.
And and,
and not only psychologically.
Not only does it offset it
psychologically because you have a
purpose and something to wake up for.
Right?
And to face the difficulties of the day,
but also because if you face the
difficulties of the day properly,
you actually ameliorate suffering not
only in the psychological sense,
but because you make the world at least
a less terrible place.
And that's something right?
To move things away from hell is
something even if you're not,
you know,
self evidently moving forthrightly to
heaven to,
to move things away from the worst they
can be as well.
That's a noble goal in and of itself.
So and,
and young people are starving for that
idea.
It's very interesting to watch.
As I look at it,
it seems to me that that actin headed
right freedom,
properly understood,
needs to be seen as a negative.
And as a positive.
The negative is,
is,
is this sort of concept of freedom from
fear,
addiction,
persecution,
Karen,
tyranny in a personal sense.
And then,
um,
freedom to be used to reach your
potential.
But it seems to me that what's missing
is an understanding that freedom
exercise within a framework of
responsibility are you doing what you
ought.
We'll guarantee you ongoing freedom for
yourself and for your neighbors.
Freedom exercised in a way that confuses
it with license tends to destroy
freedom.
In fact,
you could even go so far as to say that
misunderstood freedom turns out to be
its own worst enemy.
Well,
that's.
That's the.
That's the difficult distinction between
freedom of the moment and and freedom of
have the freedom with everything taken
into account,
and I'm a real admirer of the work of
John Piaget.
Piaget is a developmental psychologist
and few people know the world's most
well known developmental psychologists
and few people know that he was actually
motivated in his intellectual pursuits
by the desire to reconcile science with
religion.
That was his driving force from the time
that he was a young man.
You wouldn't know that even necessarily
by reading his writings because it's
implicit rather than explicit in them,
but he,
he,
he has a different model of what
constitutes morality than,
than Freud.
Freud's model is combative.
It's sort of the super ego as tyrant.
So the superego would be the strictures
of society,
the in the biological impulses,
and the eagle crushed between those.
Right?
So the ego is this thing that's crushed
between nature and culture and so it's a
really.
It's a tense and combat of model of the
human psyche and there's something about
it that's that's,
that's accurate because some of the
restrictions that are put on your
impulse gratification are imposed on you
in a,
in a sense to radically.
But Piaget's perspective was much more
optimistic and I think much more
accurate.
He noticed that as children organize
themselves spontaneously as they
developed,
especially within the confines of their
own spontaneous play,
they didn't so much subsume art or
inhibit their dark and aggressive
impulses as make them sophisticated and
transform them into universally
acceptable games.
So for Piaget,
a game that a group of children were
playing,
that all of them were playing
voluntarily and that was going well and
that they all wanted to continue playing
was a microcosm of society and literally
a microcosm of society.
The reason that children were playing
those games was to practice being
productive members of society and he
felt that the appropriate game tended
towards what he described as an
equivalent braided state.
So when a criminal braided state would
be a game that you'll play because
you've decided it's a good game,
but that you can play with others
because they've also decided that it's a
good game.
And so that can work at the individual
level and at the familial level and at
the social level.
And if you get all those things working
simultaneously,
then you have a sustainable enterprise
and it's predicated not so much on the,
on the,
uh,
inhibition of impulse or on the
regulation of it,
but of the integration of impulses into
a,
into a pattern of being that gratifies
them on a relatively permanent basis.
So,
you know,
if you want to go to university and
become a physician,
think there's a lot of,
a sacrifice of impulsive gratification
that goes along with that.
But if you become a physician,
then it's a noble enterprise.
People support you socially and all of
the needs that you need to have
fulfilled will also be fulfilled by that
enterprise.
Well,
that's a way better model and so it's
strange that the maximum freedom comes
with the adoption of a discipline and
then also the adoption of responsibility
that frees you up and everyone else
around you in the long run and if you
explain that to people,
especially in this day and age when they
be fed a never ending diet idiot rights
and freedoms,
they're immediately on board with it
because they know they know that most of
the meaning that people experience in
their life as a consequence of adopting
responsibility so they're starving for
that.
Our idea to be articulated
opens up a whole can of very,
very interesting issue.
So this try and pick a couple of,
but the do.
It's evident to me,
and I'm enormously encouraged by this
because I'm passionate Australia and I'd
want this country to be the sort of
place that offers opportunities of the
sort that I had when I was young.
I've had my opportunities.
When I look at my kids' generation,
what's going to be there for them if we
keep feeding the sort of scene grew in
reality,
the people turning out in vast numbers.
Every one of your talks in Australia's
been oversubscribed massively.
It tells you that I kind of get those
mortar,
this no know being told,
oh yeah,
they know
well.
It's one of the things that's so
interesting about dealing with
archetypal themes.
You know archetypal themes are
archetipal because they actually speak
of the structure of human experience.
That's why they last,
and so it's human nature and human
experience has a pattern.
You don't have the capacity to do
articulate that pattern as an individual
in part because your life is too short.
You just can't figure it out,
but the,
the ancient representations of those
patterns are everywhere around you and
you know some of them at the image you
caught onto them automatically you,
you,
you fall into them.
If you go to a movie,
for example,
because movies always expressed
archetipal themes.
If you hear them articulate it,
you think,
I knew that.
I just don't know how to say it.
That's,
that's the platonic idea of,
of,
um,
of learning as remembering your soul
already knows,
but it doesn't have the words.
And so when people talk to me about
watching my lectures,
let's say they say they basically say
one of two things.
If it's,
if it's not just a simple thank you.
They say one of two things.
A third of them say quarter for them,
say we're not listened to you talk.
It's as if you're telling me things that
I already know.
It's like,
yeah,
well that's exactly right because that's
what archetypal stories are there.
The description of what you already
know,
but that can be articulated.
And then who you are and how you see
yourself and the way you described
yourself are all become the same thing.
So that's wonderful.
Then you're not at odds with yourself,
you know,
and then you have,
then you're a functioning unity and that
makes you much stronger and more
indomitable than you would otherwise be.
And then the other thing that people
say,
and this is more like three quarters of
them,
is that they say,
I was in a very dark place.
I was addicted.
I was.
I was drinking too much.
I had a fragment,
good relationship with my fiance and I
wasn't getting married.
Things weren't going very well with my
family,
my relationship with my father.
It was damaged.
I didn't have any ame.
I was wasting my time.
Some variant of that,
some combination of those.
And they said,
well,
I've been watching your lectures.
I've decided to establish a purpose.
I'm trying to tell the truth and things
are way better and I've.
And so let's say I've done maybe eight
or nine large scale public talks in the
last two months.
So that's probably 20,000
people and about half of them,
a third to half of them estate
afterwards to talk to me.
So that's about 7,000
people who have said that to me.
And then people stop me on the street
all the time and tell me exactly that
story,
which is just wonderful.
Like you can't imagine how good it is to
be able to go to places you've never
been.
And to have people start people on the
streets spontaneously and say,
look,
my life is way better than it was.
It's like,
it's so good.
And so,
and I've got like,
I don't know,
35,000
letters from people since last August.
It's more than that.
I can't keep track of them.
And it's exactly the same thing,
like three quarter a quarter of them
say,
well,
you've given me the words to say what I
already knew was true.
And thank you for that.
I can see that in the audience.
It's so interesting because I can lay
out a story.
People go like this and say they're
doing that all the time.
It's like the lights are going on and
that's a really wild.
There's almost nothing better than that
to watch lights go on when you're
talking to people.
It's like that's just absolutely
fantastic.
But to get this response from people.
My father,
I haven't.
My father's about 80,
80 is 83,
I think 81.
He's 81.
And uh,
I put it in charge of going through my
viewer email,
which is an overwhelming job,
but now we've had discussions about this
constantly.
He's overwhelmed by the fact that so
many people are writing and saying the
same thing.
It's like,
well,
I have a purpose in my life actually
matters.
I finally realized that and I'm putting
it into practice and I'm bearing up
under the heaviest load I can imagine.
And it's really helping.
It's like God.
And that's tens of thousands of
responses now.
So it's,
it's.
You couldn't hope for anything better
than that.
There's zero harm in it,
right?
It's just people putting their lives
together,
they're not mucking about with other
people and are trying to make broad
scale.
Social transformation is about which
they have no idea.
They're trying to make their immediate
environment better and it's working.
It's like great.
Great.
You say the zero harm,
I'd say as a former legislator,
that there's an enormous amount of good
in a country is only the sum total of
the people that make it up.
To the extent that they put together a
resilient contribute.
Don't have to ask others to help them.
The stronger the nation,
the society and rapidly like.
I mean,
I think I was thinking the other day
because I'm a journalist asked me why
the audience by people are responding so
positively to what I'm saying.
The young men for example,
and I thought,
why?
Why?
Yeah,
that's a good question.
So that's what I'm actually on their
side.
I'm pretty happy that I'm really happy
that they're not wasting their lives.
I'm really sad to see that people are
disenchanted denialists and depressed
and anxious and aimless and and perverse
and vengeful and,
and all of those things.
It's terrible.
And then to see people question whether
that's necessary and then to start to
rise out of that.
It's like,
it's so fun.
Like last night I was at after my talk,
so overwhelming.
I don't usually think about these
things,
but I was,
I was after my talk last night and so
all these people line up and you know,
they have their 15,
15 seconds with me and they're kind of
tentative.
They're excited and attentitive when
they come up to talk to me and then they
have,
you know,
15 seconds of time to tell me something.
I'm really listening to them and they're
hesitant about whether or not to share
the good news about their life,
you know,
and I think it's often because
when people share good news about their
life,
people don't necessarily respond
positively,
you know,
they don't give encouragement and people
need so little encouragement.
It's just unbelievable.
And so there comes something good and I
think that's so good.
You know,
if somebody says,
oh,
I'm getting along better with my father,
I haven't seen him for 10 years and now
we get along great and that,
the power of that,
you can't overstate the power of that
for individuals to get their life
together.
They individuals and unbelievably
powerful force and every single person
who gets their act together a little bit
has the capacity to spread that around
them.
It's,
it's a chain reaction and so it's a
lovely thing to see and that's
fantastic.
My observation of atheists would be they
don't live like atheists.
They don't live as though they really
believe they just a cosmic accident and
there's no purpose well eater,
most of them,
the best of them.
I have a lot of respect for the atheists
generally because they've generally
thought a lot more about this situation
and struggled with it more than the
complacent fundamentalists,
you know,
who wallpaper over their doubts with,
with,
with overstatements about their belief.
The atheists,
you know the word Isaac means our
Israel.
The word Israel means he who struggles
with God.
It's like,
well,
it's not obvious that it's not the
atheists,
you know,
they're struggling away.
It's like they're obsessed with it even,
and so they have God.
We're on their mind than the typical
person who's a believer.
And so it it.
It's interesting too because there's
been this little community develop
around my biblical lectures in
particular of people who call themselves
Christian atheists,
which I think is quite remarkable.
So if I lay out the rationale for the
Christian ethic,
which is something like pick up your
damn cross and struggle uphill,
which is a really good message,
they think,
oh yeah,
well that makes a lot of sense.
It's like,
well,
I don't need the metaphysical baggage.
It's like,
well maybe you do and maybe you don't,
but even to pick up the,
the,
the practical utility of that idea,
which is overwhelming.
That's a,
that's an excellent start.
So I was going to follow on that then.
So it strikes me that a lot of young
people,
and I think this is enormously do their
credit and goes to the heart.
I think of what you're saying.
They told that morality is relative.
They don't live that way,
are looking for truth,
aren't they?
Well,
if you live that way,
everyone hates you.
You know?
But that's the grade that.
Oh yes,
yes.
But that's a good example of how you,
who you are can be out of sync with how
you represent yourself.
It's like I was walking with,
I was walking through these ideas with
the audience last night.
It's like,
well,
how do we treat each other when things
work,
you know,
and how do you treat yourself?
Well,
first of all,
you have to treat yourself like you
matter because if you don't,
then you don't take care of yourself and
you become vengeful and,
and cruel and you,
you take,
you take it out on people around you and
you're not a positive force.
None of that's good.
So you suffer more.
And so does everyone around you.
And there's a malevolence that enters
into it.
None of that's good.
So that's what happens if you don't
treat yourself like you matter.
And then what?
What happens if you don't treat other
people like they matter?
Well,
you lie to them,
you cheat them,
you steal you,
you enter into impulsive relationships
with them.
They can't trust you,
that doesn't go anywhere.
They don't like you,
you,
you end up alone at best.
And maybe like incarcerated at worst,
like that doesn't work.
And so you watched the people around you
who thrive regardless of what they say.
They act out the proposition that
everyone matters.
And then you have a functional society
and I think,
okay,
well if,
if,
if when you act out the proposition that
everyone matters,
you have a functional society,
maybe that's evidence that that
proposition is true.
It's like,
I think it's,
I think it's true.
I think the idea that the individual has
a spark of divinity within him or her,
I think there isn't a more true way of
saying that.
And if you act that out,
well this is,
goes back to the idea that you brought
up about potential,
which is also something I've discussed
with my audience is a lot.
It's like we don't act like we live in a
material reality.
We act like we face a landscape of
potential,
an external landscape of potential
within internal reservoir of potential.
That's how we act.
And then we call each other out on it.
We say things like,
well,
you're not living up to your potential
in persons go.
So yeah.
Well I know.
It's like,
well,
what do you mean by that?
What do you mean by that?
What do you mean there's more to you
than meets the eye?
Even though it's not measurable,
it's not tangible,
it's just possibility,
but everyone accepts that as though
that's a reality and we all act as if we
all act as if we make choices about what
reality to bring into,
be it we,
we,
we punish ourselves for our moral errors
and other people as well.
We act out this,
this ethic that puts us each at the
center of being as active participants
in the world that we want to bring
forward.
Everyone acts that way and if we don't,
then things go to hell instantly.
So it's like,
well,
what do we believe?
This is the argument I've had with
people like Sam Harris,
the atheist types.
It's like,
yeah,
you think you're atheist,
man.
It's like you're Christian.
Judeo Christian,
let's say to the court,
you just don't understand it.
You just don't realize it and it's
understandable,
but it's not helpful.
This idea that you put forward have a
spark of divinity in every human being,
surely lies at the heart of the miracle
of western freedom.
The idea that every individual has worth
and dignity and standing.
It's the idea that killed slavery.
Slavery is a human rights movement of
all times so successful that it
obliterated the idea that it was I had
to keep slaves,
let alone change the law.
It changed the way the world full even
though there are evil,
evil people who still keep slides and
he's a rub.
It was plainly laid by people of
profound Christian faith.
There's no other way of putting it.
Anyone who honestly,
honestly and truthfully it looks at the
history of that period,
can't get away from it,
but because it doesn't suit the modern
lifts narrative,
it's airbrushed out.
Doesn't.
That in itself says something profound
about our willingness to try and distort
truth,
to suit our object?
Say what?
What?
What it,
what it speaks of.
You know,
it's,
it's hard.
It's like the,
the white washing of what happened in
the,
in the,
in the Soviet states now in the
Communist states in the 20th century.
I mean anybody who goes through that
literature with any degree of care comes
away.
Traumatized,
right?
Shellshocked.
It's just,
it's,
it's everything the Nazis did on a
larger scale.
It's horrifying,
and yet I see with my students do 60
million people who dared to disagree
died.
Oh,
at minimum it was in their own culture.
There was something in their own society
don't know way in.
In the Soviet Union,
the estimates range from 20 to $60
million and in Mao's China,
the estimates are as much as $100,
million or a kids taught this in school.
Not at all.
Universities are very.
I say this before preference slumping.
The modern fight in it seems to me in
many ways is between what might be
called freedom and fed them for fairness
and equality.
Equality sounds terrific.
Yep.
But we've actually seen what happens in
societies where they set a quality up as
the ultimate goal.
I became terrible place.
What does that happen?
It sounds.
Yeah.
Well,
that's.
I think that's also part of the
whitewashing is we can't understand how
one of our primary moral intuitions,
which might be fairness,
let's say,
can transform itself into something so
utterly murderous when it's played out
on a large political stage,
and I think because we don't understand
that,
I mean look,
there's reasons to be on the left.
There are temperamental reasons first,
so a lot of your political preference is
influenced,
let's say,
by your temperament and a lot of your
temperament is influenced by biological
factors,
so there are temperamental reasons to be
on the left.
People who are on the left tend to be
higher and creativity and lowering
conscientiousness for,
for example.
Those are the two best predictors,
but there's also practical reasons to be
on the left and one of the practical
reasons are that human societies which
tend to be hierarchical,
like all animal societies are almost all
animal societies producing inequality as
they go about their business and
inequality is actually quite painful.
No one likes it.
Nobody,
no rich capitalist walks down a busy
urban street and sees a starving
homeless person who's clearly mentally
ill suffering madly.
And thanks that evening that inequality
is okay.
No one thinks that no one's for poverty,
right?
And so we have this moral intuition that
would be better if the downtrodden were
lifted up and it's difficult to
discriminate between that and then and
any quality narrative.
And so I think part of the reason that
we can't face the,
the lesson of the 20th century is
because it's the left that mostly has to
face the lesson and they don't know how
to reconcile their deep intuitions about
the injustice of inequality with the
fact that when you put that doctrine in
at work,
into into operation as a political tool,
you instantly stack up millions of
corpses.
We don't know what to do with that,
and so we just avoid it and that's well.
Then of course we risk replicating it,
which is not good.
That's not a good tactical move.
That's a problem.
If we don't learn from history,
we're destined to repeat it.
I entirely accept and some of those
strategies might be surprised by this.
I say I can't understand that
lifting perspective.
I think I can.
I can understand the nobility of wanting
to ensure that everyone is respected as
a full member of the of the human
family,
all of our culture and our society,
but this is where it gets tricky and
that's where I think many young people
are starting to wake up.
They're being sold a pop.
Do you have that expression in Canada?
No.
Soda Pop.
The Dod is not a sound idea that many of
the things that sound attractive don't
necessarily work,
so perhaps we need to be arguing the
case for freedom and fairness,
which will produce at least a high
degree of equality of opportunity rather
than arguing for equality,
which history tells us tends to severely
eroded freedom.
It's a harder sale because,
but it's easy to appeal to you
passionate immediately thoughtlessly,
and since that's such an instantaneously
positive moral virtue and you don't need
sophisticated argumentation to buttress
it,
it's a lot more difficult to make a cold
analytical case that the proposition
freedom first,
let's say freedom and responsibility
first lifts the bottom up better.
It's a cold argument and it requires
rationality to parse through,
so it's a harder sale.
I would argue that it's not just
rationality,
it's history.
If you bring rationality and honesty to
the study of history,
I think,
I think the,
the,
the case is actually quite compelling.
I think it is too.
I think it's open and shot.
I think it's,
it's.
Well,
there's a book that I've just been
reading that I would recommend,
um,
by a man named [inaudible],
Walter Shadelle,
and he wrote a book called the great
leveler,
which I really like.
It's an empirical analysis of
inequality.
And he had his research questions were
something like,
um,
well,
what,
what is the phenomena of inequality to
what can you attribute it and what,
if anything,
can we do to ameliorate it?
Okay.
So the first answer is something akin to
what I wrote in the first rule in my 12
rules for life,
which is,
well,
you can't lay hierarchy and inequality
at the feet of western civilization or
capitalism.
We're done with that argument.
That's wrong.
Animal societies are hierarchical and
they produce on equal distributions and
there's evidence for that in the
biological realm.
Going back a third of a billion years,
and that's happened for so long that
your nervous system has primarily
adapted to it,
so it's a deep reality and blaming it on
capitalism.
It's like,
no,
inequality's a big problem.
It's way worse than mark's thought.
Okay,
fine.
And people tend to stack up at zero.
That's a bad thing because it
destabilizes your society to have people
who are so far down in the underclass
that they have nothing to lose by
flipping the game.
That's about idea and it drives male on
male homicide as well in social science.
Evidence for that as clear.
Right?
So we want to ameliorate inequality to
some degree because we want people to
stack up at zero and d stabilize the
society and we don't want young men in
particular to become violent.
Fine.
So then shadelle takes another tack.
It's like hit his observations.
He looked at Neolithic grave sites for
signs of inequality and you see what
people are buried with.
And in one of his cases,
there's 200 people in a grave and one of
them has 190 pounds of gold and the next
richest person has like four ounces of
gold.
And then everyone else has none.
It's like.
So even in these neolithic societies and
equality was the rule hunter gatherer
societies or the same way except the
inequality isn't material because they
don't have a surplus.
Inequalities everywhere.
Okay.
So then shadelle asks two other
questions.
One is,
well,
how has it generally been reduced
pestilence and war?
That's it.
So you can reduce it.
Equality if you demolish everything
because that just brings everyone down
to zero,
but the inequality is less.
And then he does an empirical analysis
and asked a very interesting practical
question,
which is imagine that you taught it up,
the inequality coefficients of the right
wing societies,
and you did the same with the left wing
societies.
Is there a difference between the
inequality coefficients and you'd hope?
Yes,
because you'd.
You'd hope that what would happen as a
consequence of activity on the left
would be that something would actually
occur to ameliorate inequality.
He found no evidence for that
whatsoever,
so the left is sensitive to the
catastrophe of inequality,
let's say,
but their compassion oriented doctrines
designed to ameliorate that on the
positive side.
There's plenty of resentment on the left
to that,
and I don't want to sweep that under the
under the rug.
They're compassionate oriented policies
do not produce an improvement in the
equal distribution of goods.
So it's a way bigger problem than we
think.
So,
so,
and,
and putting into place these,
these thoughtless,
compassionate doctrines,
let's say putting them in place.
Again,
it's just gonna
produced exactly the same outcomes that
were produced all through the 20th
century.
We must learn again to bring the wisdom
of the past back to the table of today,
if we're to find our way out of the
malaise,
it's affecting the west,
I think,
to a better place.
But before we do that,
yep.
Um,
explore that line of thinking.
Let's go back to freedom.
All of the great sages down through the
age.
I think you make that point in this
fascinating book of yours.
I'm a obliquely at least,
uh,
particularly though the founder of
Christianity,
I think would,
would say two
a person that your personal freedom is
the thing you need to get right and
sorted first.
It's one by one.
And I'm thinking of young Australians,
so I feel so passionately about that as
I say this.
Um,
you know,
it's very easy not to be free,
very easy.
Addiction,
fear,
anxiety,
depression,
all the things that act of discipline,
lack of discipline,
your whims.
Let's go back to a society which set a
quality as its goal,
Soviet Russia,
and in the pursuit of that equality
killed 60 or 70 million.
That's the estimate of those who
disagreed,
who had a different view,
who lost their freedom of those who even
announced their own suffering because in
the Soviet Union,
if you dared to say that things weren't
going so well for you,
then you were instantly a political,
uh,
you were,
you were political criminal for
announcing your own suffering because of
the Utopian already arrived.
You understand?
And so if you were still suffering will
obviously there was something wrong with
you.
Yeah.
So imagine a society like that where
your own suffering becomes criminal.
It will.
Exactly.
Yeah.
But let's come to Alexander.
Uh,
we know a lot about what happened
because of him and he became an
incredible global figure when I was a
young man and I read his book.
The Gulag archipelago here is as men who
describes the horrors of being a
political prisoner because he disagrees,
he,
he converted.
He was originally a supporter of
communism.
He came to see how evil it was and how
oppressive it was.
He was imprisoned for having a different
view to the state ordained insistence
that everything was terrific and he
writes unbelievably that lying on his
prison bunk one day listening to the
gods beat up a fellow prisoner,
the screams and the yields.
He found freedom when he realized the
dividing line between good and evil in
fact,
didn't lie between capturing captive.
In fact,
the Giles,
we're captive to a system,
to a blonde ideology to an inability to
think trustees.
So they were perpetrating the very
system that imprison them,
not between Catholic and baptist.
He wrote,
not between woman and man,
not between black and white.
The dividing line between evil actually
lost somewhere across every human heart
playing the.
You believe it's incredibly important
that we understand.
That comes back to what you said.
I think when it's framed,
we understand it.
Everyone knows that everyone knows
because all they have to do is think
about their own transgressions.
I mean,
if you ask someone to sit for five
minutes and think,
okay,
well what mistakes have you made in your
life?
It's like hod that'll come up pretty
quickly and you can even ask people what
terrible unforgivable mistakes have you
made in your life?
Like,
yeah,
yeah.
Well we know about those too.
It's like it's no one's no one's so
naive,
you know,
unless,
unless they've really wrestled intensely
against themselves,
there's virtually no one so naive to not
be able to answer those questions.
So we know that we've done things we
shouldn't have done and we know that
we're not living up to our potential
mean,
but are we doing a truth in a massive
disservice?
Trying to imply
that there's nothing wrong with them
now.
You need for guilt,
no need for Shaman.
I need to come up with evil because the
problems,
the environment,
what are the things that so funny about
what's happening?
The problem is that you've just got to
fix society,
fixing institutions.
Well,
and then there'll be all this will
disappear.
Psychologists have been,
not all psychologists obviously,
but the psychological profession is its
neck deep in this,
in this pathology has been beating the
self esteem drum for 50 years.
Oh No,
you're okay.
You should feel good about yourself.
Like you're,
you're fine the way you are.
It's like you think,
well that's a calming message for
people.
It's like,
no,
it's not.
It's not at all.
And I watched my audiences.
It's like it's full of people in the
audience who think I'm suffering a lot
more than I think is tenable a whole
bunch of.
It's my fault.
My life is not in the order it should
be.
I know I'm doing 50 things wrong.
It's like,
what the Hell's wrong with me?
What's wrong with the people around me?
This is really serious and some well
meaning person comes up and says,
oh,
you're okay just the way you are.
It's like,
no one wants that message.
no,
I'm not okay the way I am.
I'm not okay at all the way I am.
I know that.
And so you know,
when I'm,
when I'm speaking to,
when I'm speaking now,
I say to people,
well,
you're nowhere near what you could be.
That's the,
that's the positive message.
It's like,
yeah,
you're a mass,
but you don't have to stay that way as
you're a master,
you know it.
Obviously you're suffering away like,
like so much you can barely tolerate it.
It's like,
that's okay.
You can do something about it.
So that's the thing that turns the
lights on.
It's like you could do something about
it.
Like,
oh,
so they're in a freezing prisons hill in
the most appalling circumstances.
Half stuff to death.
He funds freedom in himself.
He find something positive and something
to live for by first coming to grips
with it,
evil and understanding what it is a
conundrum in.
Then he said to like,
and,
and he,
he underwent the Christian process of
Metanoia,
which is to go over your.
It's,
it's,
it's confession essentially.
Unrepentant wasn't mediated by religious
structure Solzhenitsyn's case,
but it was exactly the same process and
he knew that perfectly well.
I'm not making this up.
He said when he was in the prisons and
decided that he was at least in part to
blame for his own imprisonment and the
imprisonment of everyone around him that
that was his fault or at least his
response,
both his fault and his responsibility
that he was going to take that on.
He said the first thing he did was he
went over his life with a fine tooth
comb in memory,
and his goal was,
okay,
I'm going to remember everything I did
when in my life up to now where I did
something that I knew to be wrong and
not because of some external authority
defining it as wrong,
but in relationship to his own
conscience.
Right?
Um,
and then he was going to determine if
there was some way that can be rectified
now to atone for it,
right.
To to become at one with it again,
and so that was part of the process he
undertook and the concluding consequence
of that was that he wrote the Gulag
archipelago,
which is absolutely overwhelming.
That blew the intellectual slats out of
the foundation of communism permanently.
Right?
One solution isn't published until now.
We shouldn't be trying to gloss over.
Academia seems to be full of people who
want to soft pedal and reinstitute this
naive view that if we just create the
right institutions,
everybody will behave rationally,
will all be equal,
everything will be okay.
They want to reinforce it.
Won't say that,
but that's where they want to do.
They want to enforce it.
Yeah.
Well,
I think it's easy and it's only a few
short decades since all of that
happened.
Yeah.
Well,
are we mad?
we're.
We're characterized by inertia and
ignorance.
It's not easy.
It's not easy to understand history.
It's especially not if you read it
properly,
you know,
you read.
I had a client at one point who was an
unbelievably naive person.
You cannot overestimate her naivete no
matter how hard you try.
Her parents taught her that,
that adults were angels,
literally,
and she believed that in a strange sense
when I met her,
she was in her twenties and,
uh,
and she had this extraordinarily naive
view of people and had been hurt.
And if you're very naive and you've been
hurt by someone,
you often disintegrate because it blows
your world apart.
That's what had happened to her.
And I said she had a university degree
and I said,
well,
look,
like,
um,
in,
in the liberal arts.
I said,
didn't you read any history?
And she said,
well,
yeah.
And I said,
well,
how did not disturb the whole adults are
angels hypothesis?
And she said,
well,
I read it,
but I just compartmentalize it.
And that gave me a key to what was wrong
with her and we successfully dealt with
it.
But I had her to begin her process of
cure,
oddly enough,
because she had to understand
malevolence because she had been touched
by it,
right?
She had to understand it because her
naive worldview had been shattered by
the hand of malevolence.
I had to read a book called ordinary
men,
um,
by Browning,
and
it's the study of these Polish
policeman,
a German policemen who were sent to
Poland after the Nazis had marched
through Poland and they were sent to
police Poland and they were know decent
middleclass guys,
essentially most of whom had been hit
maturity before Hitler had come to
power.
So they weren't indoctrinated.
Nazis,
you know,
not,
not like the Nazi youth types were.
And they had to go to Poland and and be
policemen under wartime conditions.
And they had a very humane commander and
he told all of them that they were going
to have to do things that would be far
more brutal in all likelihood that they
were normally prepared to do in.
They're in Seville,
in the role as,
as,
as non military policemen,
but that they could go back to their old
job if they wanted to.
So it wasn't top down enforcement of an
authoritarian ethos and browning
documents their transformation.
The guy next door,
you know,
the policeman next door and to people
who were taking naked pregnant women out
into fields and shooting them in the
back of the head and it's a brutal book
because while these men that's like,
it just ruined the to do that to
themselves.
They were physically ill during the
process of transformation,
you know,
and,
and he does a very good job of
documenting how an ordinary person
transforms into a,
a Nazi murderer.
And I had to read that.
I said,
but don't you compartmentalize it?
This is about you,
right?
This isn't about someone else.
When you read history you think,
well that's about someone else.
It's like,
unless maybe you're a victim and you
identify with the victims,
it's a very rare person who reads
history and identifies with the
perpetrators.
But unless you read history and identify
with the perpetrators,
then you don't understand history at
all.
And so who wants to understand that?
And I get my students.
I said,
look,
I've told him this for 30 years.
Here's something you have to understand.
If you were in Nazi Germany,
the statistical probability is
overwhelming that you would have been a
perpetrator,
right?
You think you would have rescued and
frank.
It's like,
think again.
Those people are very,
very,
very rare.
They put their lives on the line to do
that.
They put their family's lives on the
line to do that.
You think you're one of those people
really like that.
All that means is that you know nothing.
You know nothing about yourself.
You know nothing about people you know
nothing about politics or economics or
history.
It's a harsh lesson by truth about
Germany in the 19 thirties.
It was probably the most educated
society,
the world,
and seen to that point in time.
Education alone,
cleverness in inverted commas alone,
intelligence alone,
civil right,
right,
right.
So absolutely there's no substitute for
character.
So we don't want pascal cold about the
cold talk to the glory and the scum to
reach our full humanity.
It seems to me we need to understand
both intention now,
Carl Young,
the unbelievable scum that laws in terms
of our potential at the bottom of every
heart,
the extraordinary nobility,
you call it the spark of divinity,
I would say,
made in the image of an of a mighty
creator.
You've got to hold those things in
suspension if you're,
if you've defined your real humanity and
in fact have a good place is surely
through the valley of darkness in the
first place.
You know,
that's you think,
well,
if it's possible to be enlightened,
heightened,
why isn't everyone enlightened?
It's like,
well,
you don't get to paradise.
You don't get to heaven without
Harrowing Health First.
Right?
And who's going to do that?
Like that's a terrible thing to do.
It isn't even clear that you can survive
it.
No,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's brutally damaging to come to terms
with your own proclivity for malevolence
and so people don't do it and it's no
wonder.
But,
but the funny thing is,
and this is also something that I think
that,
that people have been watching,
my lectures have been attracted by,
especially the young man.
It's like until you know your,
until you understand that you're a
monster,
until perhaps you even develop that as a
capacity.
You don't have the moral forced to do
good,
and so not only is that dissent to begin
with,
s s necessary to scare you straight,
right to make you understand what
exactly it is that you're dealing with,
but you don't even have the strength of
character to be good until you
understand just exactly what sort of
monster you can be.
I have a rule in my book,
rule five,
do not let your children do anything
that makes you dislike them.
It's a meditation on the monstrousness
of parents.
It's like,
don't underestimate yourself,
your capability to ruin your children's
lives.
You let them act in a manner that makes
you disapprove of them.
You will take revenge on them in ways
you cannot even imagine.
Unless you understand that you're not
going to be careful enough as a parent
and you're not going to set proper
boundaries,
don't let your children and Noi you.
It's a very bad idea.
Now you know that means that you should
try to regulate your proclivity to be
annoyed and you should try to be
civilized and you should talk to your
partner,
your wife or your husband about your
oversensitivities and foolishness.
But having said that,
you need to know who the monster is and
it's you.
So,
so if we're washing that wisdom out,
I don't want to sound condemnatory here
are more sympathetic and concern for
what's happening in our family homes
and,
and the environment in which our kids
are being raised.
And you and I,
I mean,
you're very passionate in your concern
for those people.
So we don't want anyone to think he had.
We're trying to condemn them for the
opposite.
Just the opposite.
But if we're watching this out of the
system,
what then happens to our kids when they
hit institutions,
schools,
colleges,
universities.
Well,
we're gonna.
Find out because increasingly the
elementary and the school systems that
our kids are going through from say the
age of five to the age of 18 are
increasingly occupied by the postmodern
neo Marxists theologies.
Um,
I think we have to learn to identify
what those are.
That's a start.
I mean there's buzzwords,
diversity,
inclusivity,
equity,
that's a,
that's a no go zone.
Equity,
that's equality of outcome.
That's a preposterous murderous doctrine
masquerading in sheep's clothing.
Um,
white privilege,
systemic racism,
gender,
all of those.
None of those as individual topics
aren't necessarily off the table,
you know,
and you can have an intelligent
discussion about any of them except
equity because that's just a no go zone.
But to see those,
those,
those concepts emerge as a,
as a network of meaning,
you know,
that you're in the presence of this,
this pernicious,
postmodern,
Neo Marxist doctrine that's
fundamentally ideological at its core.
And people need to see that and they
need to understand what that means and
they need to stop it.
Now how they're going to stop it,
they're going to make a million
individual decisions about that,
but at least they could start by
identifying,
and I've suggested to parents in,
in Canada,
in the US,
that as soon as teachers talk to their
children about diversity,
inclusivity and equity,
that they,
they suggest to their children that they
leave the class because they're no
longer in the educational realm.
They're in the indoctrination realm and
people aren't taking that.
I wouldn't say they're not taking that
seriously.
It's not an easy thing to figure out and
it sounds very,
very radical to,
to,
to suggest,
you know,
encouraging your children to leave the
class.
But I think we're at that point,
we wonder why our universities in our
high quality courses in how freedom was
secured by Western societies for its
individual member,
uh,
people,
and how it might be secured and how you
secured fairness from unfairness.
Those sorts of things are not there.
Well,
some of it,
I think some of it has to do with what
we've been speaking about is that to,
to,
to address the problem squarely is
actually quite daunting.
We knew the difficulties are manifold.
Inequality is real,
individual malevolence is real.
To constrain it inside yourself is
extraordinarily daunting.
To read history as a perpetrator is
traumatizing.
These are hard things,
and then to think through the problems
of addressing something like inequality
instead of reacting to it in a knee
jerk,
compassionate manner in that and
implement policies on that basis that
are going to be counterproductive.
That's also extraordinarily difficult.
So there's difficulty is part of it,
and then I would also say,
well,
we haven't talked about the resentment
that drives the discussion of
inequality.
It's not all.
It's not like every one on the left is
overwhelmed by compassion and that's why
all these brutal things tend to happen.
It's that they're also overwhelmed by
the same sort of jealousy that Kayden
had for Abel and the same sort of
murderous impulses that emerge very
rapidly.
As a consequence of that jealousy.
He has more than me.
He must be a perpetrator.
It's morally obligatory for me to take
him out.
That's an easy message to sell.
I read about how the communists deep,
Deep Kula cooler heist the Russian
countryside.
So imagine,
imagine Russia,
you're in a village,
it's 30 years,
something like that.
After the service have been emancipated,
there's a few agriculturalists who've
managed to produce successful
agricultural enterprises and you know,
maybe they have a couple of cows,
they have some land,
they're able to hire a few people and
they're raising almost all the foot.
Right?
And so.
And they're a minority in any village
because the hyper productive successful
are always a minority.
So they're minority in every village.
All right.
And so and,
and there's people who are doing worse
and then there's a lot of people who
aren't doing so well at all and then the
communist intellectual show up and they
tell the people who aren't doing so
well,
some of whom are just suffering because
of life,
but some of whom aren't doing well
because they've never done anything
productive with even a second of their
life.
And the communist intellectuals come in
and say,
you know,
those guys that are doing so much better
than you.
Yeah,
they actually stole that from you and
you're morally obligated to go take it
back.
It's like,
Oh man,
you know,
after after six cups of mead,
let's say,
or let's say 10 or let's say 20 and I'm
drunk out of my mind and I've got my
crew of buddies with me and we're all
resentful,
right to the core because we've wasted
our miserable lives and now we have an
opportunity to go like down the street
to our wealthy neighbors house and to
rape his daughters and we can do it in
the name of good.
It's like,
well,
there's a story you can market.
And that happened everywhere in the
Soviet Union,
and so they wiped out the Kulaks.
It's like,
great.
And then 6 million Ukrainian starve to
death.
Right.
Brilliant.
I'm a Pharma.
Do your crime was the breadbasket of
Europe.
That's what it was.
Then it became a region pathetically
unable to feed itself and yet the same
sort of world view that gave rise to
that.
We're now being told you use the word
neo Marxist.
Uh,
many people in Australia use the word
cultural Marxist have got an old friend
who said to me,
uh,
what are you talking about,
John?
And I free capitalist Australia is not
going to let that happen here.
Well,
Quanta's airlines took a nice step
towards that the other day and they
adopted their language policing
policies.
These corporate,
these corporations who should know far
better let these far left fifth columns
into their organizations.
They think they're not going to pay for
that.
I think they're going to stop with some
demands for the reconstruction of
language.
Not like the demands for reconstruction
of language by the way are trivial.
There may be the most important thing
you could possibly demand,
right?
I want to reshape the way you speak.
I want to reshape the way you think.
It was like,
oh,
that's okay.
As long as it doesn't interfere with the
bottom line.
It's like huddle interfere with the
You let that fifth column in.
It's a warning to corporate people.
You let that fifth column in,
man,
you're gonna regret it.
You're going to regret it.
So.
And things can turn on a dime.
You know,
a very well organized minority,
even if the majority of poses them and,
and they do very well organized minority
can have an unbelievably pernicious
effect on,
uh,
on our organization.
Margaret Mead's made that point when a
small group of people decided to change
its direction that that's the way
history works.
Well,
that's what happened in the
universities.
It's come back to this issue of the
redefining of language.
It seems to me that there are two things
that people would want to reshape
society and brutal ways,
uh,
do.
The first
is they start the silence,
good debate.
Either silence or shut it down or
whatever.
Second thing they do is they redefined
language.
So it's very hard to have a debate.
So diversity actually,
I mean there's no other way to put it in
this country is rapidly coming to mean a
stifling conformity.
You cannot not deviate from the line.
Uh,
and you see it with a whole lot of other
words that are bandied around.
Equality being one of them because it's
confused.
Equality of opportunities,
confused with the quality of our.
Well,
the initial wedge was equality of
opportunity.
And that flu and and so while.
No,
no,
it's equality of outcome.
That's equity and that's,
I cannot believe how rapidly that idea,
which is the ultimate and terrible
ideas.
I can't believe how rapidly that spread
and how little people criticize it.
Well,
that's a couple it to uninformed
analysis.
It sounds good if you're feeling
carelessly.
Okay.
Passionate.
Because you got back to the Ukrainian
example in destroying the leading edge
farmers.
You actually guaranteed misery forever.
Oh,
on unbelievable.
People were selling human body parts in
the Ukraine for food.
You know,
it was.
If you were a mother and your children
were starving and you went out into the
fields after they were harvested and you
picked up individual pieces of grain
that the harvesters had left and you
didn't turn them over to the state.
That was a capital offense.
Right.
That's,
that was the funny thing is that that
was in the glory days of the Russian
revolution,
right?
That wasn't in the 19 fifties.
That wasn't in the 19 thirties even.
That was in the 19 twenties.
That was right when this started and I
think it was,
I think it was Malcolm Muggeridge who
was reporting on that for,
for a UK newspaper,
whose name escapes me at the moment.
He was pointing all this out and no one
paid it.
Attention,
attention towards the end of his life.
He warned that the west is in danger of
eating itself out from within and I
wonder whether in fact he wasn't being
very appreciative and you and I want to
stop that happening for the sake of our
young people,
for the sake of everyone.
We went down that pathway already.
We need to do that things.
History should be like science in the
sense that it ought to be objective,
but ought to be told truthfully it was
not to be used to secure some dominant
groups,
preferred version of society.
Well,
this is also why.
See what I've been trying to do about
this because I've thought this through.
A long time ago,
I thought,
well,
I don't want to.
I think the group identity game ends in
blood.
It doesn't matter who plays it.
Left wingers,
play it blood right wingers,
play it lots and lots of it,
not just a little bit.
You can't play the identity politics
game.
Also,
what do you do instead you.
You live the mythologically heroic life
as an individual.
That's the right place to work and
that's the message of the as far as I'm
concerned,
is that we figured that out.
We figured out that the collective
identity was not the pinnacle statement
that the individual,
not the collective identities have no
value.
Obviously family has value and and and,
and your organizations have value,
all of that.
That's not the issue.
The issue is what's the paramount value?
What's the metric by which people should
be measured and the answer is they
should be measured as individuals,
as if they have a divine soul.
It should be measured in that manner,
but it can't be a selfish thing.
That is to say,
if I recognize I have worth and dignity,
I'm obliged to recognize it.
So you,
Huh?
I think you can recognize that you have
intrinsic worth and dignity without also
doing without also recognizing and then
others and vice versa.
I don't think that I can recognize the
worth of another person without,
without stumbling onto the idea that I
also have to recognize that for myself.
When did you think while everyone would
want that,
but what?
People don't because you're also charged
with the responsibility of your own care
as if you matter.
Well,
that's a big responsibility.
Like it's a lot easier to assume that
everything is pointless.
I mean that's painful and all of that,
but.
Well,
you don't bear any responsibility and no
one lives that way.
No,
no.
Well No.
Not for long.
Exactly.
But you know,
Voltaire's biographer wasn't actually
vegetarian,
so if it was a lady hit rowdy's,
well one of the mini biographies of him
in the Nineteen thirties came up with
that adage,
summarizing his views that I may
disagree with you,
but I'll defend to the death your right
to say it.
There's a couple of things implicit in
that that seemed to be incredibly
important,
so I may disagree with you,
but you have dignity and standing and
worth and a right to put your view.
That's the first thing,
I'm respecting the other person or you
should crave it.
Yeah,
and the second thing it implies is that
the idea on the table that's important
for two reasons.
One is we need to have a debate about
that.
Not attack the person who put it there,
show some respect for.
The second thing is
only bond,
almost debate that you find the best way
forward.
That's the thing that then that ties
back to the discussion we had about the
purpose of memory and the purpose of of
historical education.
It's like,
look,
there's a rule in my book which is rule
nine,
assuming that the person that you're
listening to know something,
you don't,
well,
they do the person you're listening to
know some things you don't.
You can be sure of that.
Now whether or not you can get to them
is a different matter,
but if you do get to them,
it's a real deal for you.
That's why you want to listen to the
other person's argument says,
because you're not everything you could
be.
You don't know the pathway forward with
as much clarity as you could and it's
possible.
This is one of the wonderful things that
I've had the privilege of experiencing
as a clinician,
you know,
because people,
it's like I live inside a Dostoyevsky
novel as a clinician.
People come in and they tell me about
their lives and I listened to them and
they tell me things that are just
absolutely beyond belief,
you know,
and I learn from my clients constantly
there.
They're telling me honestly about their
experience.
They tell me things they wouldn't tell
anyone else because I actually listened
to them,
but part of the reason I listened is
because I'm desperate to listen.
It's like there's a possibility I'm
going to do something stupid in the next
five years that's going to be like
fatal.
And there's some small possibility that
if we have a decent discussion that
you'll tell me something that will
eliminate some of my blindness so that I
don't have to fall into that particular
pitt.
And if you have a good sensitivity for
the depth of the pit,
then you know you're pretty bloody
motivated to avoid it.
And so,
and that and that,
that dialogue is,
it's,
it's dialogic,
it's Daya Logos,
right?
It's shared logos.
It's the way that we redeem ourselves
mutually moving forward,
have old,
depends on having the facts on the
table,
especially you're able to establish them
not distortions,
effect,
not what you wish would be the case,
at least your best approximation of what
you think to be true and not what you
wish for Helen,
because it never seems to be a,
if I disagree with what you say,
Oh,
painted as hate speech or challenging to
my notions of diversity and
inclusiveness on all fought to the
death.
Your right to even have your say.
Well that's why hate speech laws are so
pernicious.
It's like.
And that needs to be taken apart.
First question,
is there such a thing as hate speech?
Yes.
Obviously people say terrible things,
reprehensible things,
quasi criminal things even all the time.
Brutal.
And some of them cause a lot of trouble.
So the idea that there's hateful speech,
it's like,
yeah,
okay,
that's self evident.
No problem.
Well,
let's regulate it.
Okay,
fair enough.
Because it's hateful,
you know,
maybe we'd rather that there wasn't any
of it.
Okay,
no problem.
Who defines hate?
Well,
we'll worry about that later.
It's like,
no,
you won't.
That's actually the problem.
Here's the answer to who defines hate?
Those people that you would least want
to have defined it.
That will be the inevitable consequence
of the legislation because sensible
people won't have anything to do with
that.
Like people who are power mad will
gravitate to that domain to make an
ethical case to exercise their
controlling power over the language of
other people know.
And I have had journalists say,
well,
what makes you think that you're right
to free speech?
Trump's the right of someone to not be
offended.
And I think that's really the level of
our political discourse.
Okay,
so we'll run a little thought
experiment.
So I'm talking to one person.
I'm talking to you and the rule is I
don't get to offend you.
Okay.
Maybe we can still have a discussion
about something difficult,
but let's say I'm talking to 10 people
and about an important thing.
Now I have to make sure that I don't say
anything to fight despite the fact that
this isn't important and contentious
issue,
that I don't say anything that offends
even one of those 10 people.
Okay,
maybe I can even manage that.
What if I'm talking to a thousand
people?
There's going to be somewhat in that
thousand people,
there's going to be someone who's
offended at the mere fact that I exist,
so it's an impossible standard.
It's like,
well,
you can't say anything offensive.
Okay,
fine.
Then you can't say anything.
Okay,
so what?
You don't get to say anything because no
one should be offended.
Well then you don't get to think,
well,
what happens if you don't think,
well then you can't negotiate your way
through the future and you fall into a
pit and so does everyone else.
So that's where that all ends up.
You can't say offensive things equals
you cannot negotiate your way properly
through the future equals everyone
suffers.
Well,
that's a bad.
That's a bad strategy.
So and it's.
And it's all covered up with,
well,
you know what?
Be better if no one was ever offended.
It's like,
well,
who thinks that you know how naive you
have to be to think that how you have to
be pathologically naive,
which is the kind of naive that you
could have grown out of,
but you willfully refused to because you
weren't willing to see what was in front
of your face and then you impose that
blind naivety on everyone else because
you don't want to allow them to upset
your like rosy view,
your rosy view of yourself and the
world.
It's just there's no end to how terrible
that is.
Yes,
so one of our very astute writers
recently made the comment that freedom
of speech is the most important freedom
because it's the freedom by which we
defend all about other freedoms.
It strikes me that freedom of speech
though is most important,
not for the powerful of the elites.
It's actually for the minority groups.
A free society surely is one that allows
those who swim against the tide and have
a different perspective.
The right to do so without fear of mob
or state sanction.
I,
you've had some personal experience
while I gave a talk and the University
of British Columbia about a year ago,
it was called leftwing case for freedom
of speech.
It's like it's really easy to make a
left wing case for freedom of speech.
It's like,
well,
that's how I dispossessed.
How have the opportunity to make their
suffering known,
right?
Yeah.
Clearly.
I mean it's,
it's the fact that that argument even
has to be made shows you how
pathological the radical left has become
because it's clearly the case that
freedom of speech is not generally in
the interests of the power elite,
right?
Because they already have access to,
to what they need to maintain their grip
on the world.
Let's say.
If you look at those in that manner,
it's the people at the bottom of the
hierarchy who's right to expression
needs to be protected.
If you're in control of the debate,
you don't need freedom of speech.
Right,
and obviously so it's useful for the
dispossessed of freedom of speech issue.
And then the other issue that you wrote
that the writer that you described,
rope a rope,
brought to the forefront,
is the idea of the hierarchy of rights.
Now in our,
in our conception of rights in Canada,
we're not willing to assume that any
reit has priority over any other right
now,
that doesn't work out because when the
two rights come into conflict with one
another,
which they do,
you have to adjudicate their relative
status.
And what's happened in Canada is that
equality rights keep trumping everything
else and that's not good.
It's actually a good reason why you
shouldn't have a bill of rights and we
never should have had one in my
estimation,
but whatever the freedom of speech,
you say,
well,
speeches,
the,
the right to freedom of speech is
central because it's the right by which
you defend all the other rights.
Well,
that's why the idea of logos in the West
is the most sacred concept,
right?
The cause of Christ.
Think about this psychologically,
is Christ is the,
is the ideal of perfection.
Now,
this is the independent of any religious
discussion,
any historical accuracy.
It doesn't matter.
We're looking at this from the
perspective of the analysis of a myth or
story.
What Christ represents is the perfect
individual,
whatever that is.
Now,
you discussed endlessly what that is,
but one of the things the West has
settled on is the idea.
Well,
that is that the perfect individual
otters,
the truthful speech that makes potential
into habitable order,
does that through truth.
Now it's embedded in the first few
sentences in,
in genesis,
for example,
when,
when God brings the world into being so
and and the idea that that truthful
speech that brings the world into being
from formulas,
potential also characterize as each
person.
That's our,
our,
for our fabrication in the image of God.
That's the idea of the West.
It's unbelievably remarkable idea that
perfection individual perfection is to
be found in a relationship with spoken
truth.
God,
that's,
that's a great idea.
Well,
it's out of that arises the observation
that there's no,
there's nothing more central to the
hierarchy of rights and obligations as
well,
let's say.
Then freedom of speech.
Yes,
it's absolutely central.
That's why Christ is the word made
flesh.
The idea is that the perfect individual
is the person who's,
while who speaks truth,
but also acts out the truth of those
words,
it's a very,
it's a,
it's a proposition who's merit is
virtually self evident when you
understand it in that manner.
So yeah,
I keep two,
two c assaults on freedom of speech,
especially compelled speech.
Well,
that's where I drew the line in,
in my life.
It was like preps that's held speech
legislation in Canada.
Perhaps that's why the lift so
determined in this country to get
Christianity out of the classroom,
but to lose something of the children.
There's no doubt.
That's why they're determined.
I mean people like Derrida,
I mean he called the West Fowl logo
centric,
right?
Male dominated logos centric.
It's like that is the west.
It's a logo centric.
If you want to take the west down,
you remove the idea of the divine word
from the substructure of the society,
so you have to do that.
It's like,
and this is the level at which this war
is being fought,
it's fundamentally a theological war.
Interesting.
Like to think that,
but it is a famous Waterloo lectures
blaze Pat,
the inaugural Blaise Pascal lecture in
1978.
I'm Malcolm Muggeridge,
said the waste was in danger of eating
itself out from within.
And he spoke at great length about this
attempt to,
um,
about how the West was abandoned in
Christianity and it'll become a very
empty and soulless and financially
bankrupt places a result.
But it wouldn't be the end.
He said,
despite the attempts to kill it in
places like communist China and Russia,
there will always be people who will
fight through to the truth.
Of course,
we can see now three decades own
whatever,
that he was absolutely right,
closer to four decades.
And he was right.
Well,
you know,
that Christianity is spreading faster in
communist China than it did in Rome
during its most rapid period of
expansion in terms of proportion of
people transforming.
So Christianity is spreading incredibly
quickly in China,
which is who would have guessed that,
right?
I mean,
that's,
that just makes you,
makes you shake your head.
Tell us a little more about your Chilean
experience.
I mean Canada and Australia culturally
in many ways,
very like if it can happen in in Canada,
presumably he's coming here.
Oh,
it's how it's going to happen here.
I think it's absolutely inevitable.
It's not that big a move from where
you're already at and the fact that
while the quantas airline thing is a
really good example,
the fact that these things are happening
and that corporations aren't standing up
in outrage against the introduction of
ideas like equity.
It's like you guys are all primed for
this.
Why not compelled speech?
Especially if it's done for the best of
all possible reasons.
I was accused of denying the identities
of the oppressed.
It's like,
well,
for me that wasn't the issue at all at
all.
You know?
She was,
no,
look,
I'm not an advocate of hate speech laws
for the reasons I've already described.
It's like who's going to define hate?
Not In the people you want to define it.
For sure.
That's what's going to happen.
That's bad enough,
but then to say,
well,
I have to use the language of my
detestable radical leftists,
leftists photos.
Let's say that's not happening,
so,
and that's what I said,
so you go videos,
some of the most wonderful Australians
on our corporate leaders and you know,
the generous philanthropic,
they thoughtful they're contributors to
the public debate,
but I'd have to say far too many of them
seem,
I'll use the expression piggy ignorant
of the reality that they are playing
with.
They're playing with cultural forces
that will destroy the very activities
that they would hold up as being central
to our wealth and prosperity.
Those cultural forces are playing with
them.
Oh yes.
So those are astute people can't
realize,
don't see there being toyed with there
being toyed with,
with,
with demonic forces in a sense.
And again,
I mean that in a psychological sense,
Carl Jung said,
people don't have ideas.
Ideas have people just like you would
think about that for about five years.
You know,
like the,
if you take the typical student radical
out of their demonstration and you have
a chat with them one on one,
you find out that,
you know,
they're the daughter of the guy down the
street that you wave to,
you know,
while she was growing up and that 80
percent of her is sensible person,
you know,
and 10 percent is resentful and 10
percent is ideologically possessed
partly because of the machinations of or
idiot professors and so she's okay,
but if you get 10 of her together and
each of them are 10 percent possessed,
then you have the whole devil in the
room.
Right.
And that thing has a will.
It has a historical will and you better
not be thinking you're running the show,
especially if you're ignorant of the
process and the corporate types who are
letting the radical left fifth column
into their midst and mostly through
their human resources,
their human resources departments,
which would,
should probably just be shut down.
They have no idea what they're missing,
what they should watch,
what happens to google.
I'll have to say I've been pretty
stunned by two or three of the senior
chairman in this country who have said
to me or said to friends of mine in the
context of recent politically correct
the bites here,
that they'd been startled themselves by
wall.
The companies underneath of them have
said [inaudible],
which raises some interesting questions
about they need to get up to speed.
They're not startled enough.
So I've watched.
I've seen many people have sent me the
sorts of training programs,
but the diversity consultants are
foisting on the corporate world.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's as if a woman's studies program has
been placed in the midst of the
corporate environment.
It's the.
It's not only,
it's not only the academic left,
let's say,
made,
made manifest in,
in a powerpoint presentation.
It's the worst elements of the activist.
Academically.
The most appalling parts of the
university are making themselves
manifest in the corporate world at an
amazing rate and the corporations are
guilty partly because,
well,
partly because of inequality.
I would say they're guilty and they
wanted wallpaper over there.
Bad Conscience with with some hand
waving to to the equality pushers.
It's like,
well,
play with that at your peril.
So it's a very bad idea.
Diversity,
inclusivity,
equity.
That's a bad game if you're going to be
burned,
if you play it and in ways you can't
imagine.
So great.
Already.
Freedom Fan was respectful.
Debate
a lot.
That's right.
Responsibility,
justice,
that is a good one.
Let's circle back to young people
because the future is going to belong to
them before we know it.
A remarkable and very insightful and
engaging human being.
Jonathan Heit is perhaps a lad in
example,
of somebody who's seen from a left
perspective himself had dangerous all of
his ears on how we're endangering young
people by not being honest with them,
not encouraging them to,
to explore what they instinctively feel
needs to be explored going back to our
earlier topic and when leaving them
without the resilience that they going
to need to confirm if you like a free
and prosperous society.
And,
uh,
I had a Christian,
he run relating to this,
which I'd just like to read,
uh,
in his piece,
the coddling of the American mind,
Jonathan Heit outlines why millennials
today are so fragile and lacking
resilience in life and in relationships
in university courses in the workplace,
and what has led to this overwhelming
push to be protected from anything
difficult or uncomfortable or offensive.
And he calls it the flight to safety.
And I think you've used that expression,
um,
he outlines the core reason for this
fragility of mind and emotion.
He says it stems firstly from
overfunctioning and over protective
parents.
Then schools,
now Richard's into our university just
because more people than ever go to
universities in the waste.
So they formed a much bigger bulk in our
community afterwards and it leaves them
tragically unprepared and unarmed for
life and relationships.
Would you comment on.
I think it's good to take a step back
from that and think about it in the
broadest possible terms.
There is definitely an epidemic of
overprotective parenting,
but it's useful to ask why.
And my suspicions are,
is that this is driven by very
fundamental,
biological and cultural phenomena that
aren't generally considered in
relationship to this issue.
We don't have very many children.
We don't have
12,
you know,
six of who die.
We have one or two
and that makes them very precious,
right?
We're unwilling to take risks with them
and no wonder.
And then we also have the much later in
life.
And so like if you have a kid when
you're 18,
you're still a kid,
you know,
you're gonna go out and have your life,
right?
Because you're so while you're in the,
in the height of your exploratory,
you're,
you're in the height of the exploratory
part of your life.
You're not going to overprotect your kid
because you're still a kid.
But if you're 40 and you have one child,
it's like all your eggs are in one
basket.
And the probability that you're going to
take undue risks with that precious
person is very,
very low.
Now obviously there's some advantages to
that because great,
you would devote resources to your
child,
you know,
and foster their development.
But the downside is that you have every
motivation to hover and maybe you're
also extraordinarily desperate as a
mother to maintain that bond with your
child because you struggled so long to
achieve it.
It's highly,
highly valuable.
You can't take a risk well.
So these.
So what we might say,
well perhaps over protective parenting
is a secondary and unintended
consequence of the birth control pill.
And the fact that people now have
children later in life could easily be,
you know,
if you have six kids,
it's like,
what are you gonna?
Do a helicopter parent them?
It's like,
no,
you're so tired.
You can't even get off the couch.
If you have six kids and they're.
They outnumber you,
right?
They're raising each other.
They're competing and they're taking
each other down a peg.
They're not.
There's no overprotection there,
but with a single child landscape or
dual child landscape,
mostly a single child landscape.
Then you're going to overprotect and
then that ethos starts to permeate the
schools and it starts to permeate the
higher education institutions as those
children mature.
And then that all reinforces it.
Not Good.
It's not obvious what to do about it
either,
because if it is driven by demographics
in that,
in that sense,
it's a much more intractable problem
that we think.
So.
I did some of that in 12 rules for life,
you know,
I said,
look,
what you have to understand is that
you're a danger to your children no
matter what.
Right?
You can let them go out into the world
and be hurt or you can overprotect them
and hurt them that way.
So you,
here's your choice.
You can make your children competent and
courageous or you can make them safe,
but you can't make them safe because
life isn't safe.
So if you sacrifice their courage and
competence on the altar of safety,
then you disarmed them completely and
all they can do is pray to be protected.
That's so in the very act of trying to
do the right thing by them.
Although often with a selfish motive,
right off roading,
we scrip why the tools and the
equipment,
the understanding they really need to
make life work.
Oh,
that's the.
That's the diploma mother,
right?
That was Freud's great discovery of the
dark mother.
The dark mother is the person.
She's the witch in Hansel and Gretel.
Gingerbread house.
Lost Children.
Too.
Good to be true.
It's like a house of candy.
Wow.
Who could want anything better?
What lives inside the House of Candy,
the which that wants to fatten you up
and eat you.
Right.
A cautionary tale about over protective
parents,
over protective mothers about the over
protective feminine.
It's like the psychoanalysts.
They were so smart,
said the good mother necessarily fails
at such a brilliant phrase.
It's like you can't.
As you,
as your child matures,
you have to fail more and more as a
mother,
right.
Until by the time you're 30,
you're your child's 30,
let's say 25 for that matter.
You're not their mother anymore.
I mean obviously you are,
but the relationship has hit something
like quasi peer status,
not entirely obviously,
but the child's independent able to
stand up on their own two feet and take
on the world.
Now we say the university student runs
into some difficulties with study or
whatever.
Brings a parents in to talk to the
faculty.
Yeah.
Or they go off in color,
I mean when I went to Queens University
a week ago and there was a lot of noise
and and horror around that,
you know,
that the people who were decrying my
visit set up coloring book stations so
that people could be comforted because
you know,
the evil professor was coming to talk.
It's like,
and you know,
as a clinician and height knows this as
well,
and all the clinicians worth their salt.
No,
this.
The worst thing you can do for someone
who's anxious is overprotect them.
It makes them worse.
The clinical literature on that is
crystal clear.
What you do for people who are hyper
anxious is gradually expose them with
their voluntary consent to increasingly
threatening situations that cures them.
It's exactly the opposite of what all
the mental health professionals so and I
use that term extraordinarily lightly,
are trying to do to produce safe spaces
on the university campus.
Like if as safe as a space needs to be
defined as safe,
you can be sure that's the one thing.
It is not.
Jordan,
this has been fascinating.
Let me pay you a compliment.
In some ways,
I think the most valuable thing you can
do for us is to model the courage to
speak your mind.
You do it forcefully,
you do it courageously,
you do it compassionately because the
reality is you only have to spend a bit
of time with you to realize that you
actually care,
especially about our young people and
what they're experiencing and especially
for our young men because we know boys
model themselves,
all men who they respect you.
They are a great job of modeling
in the face of,
well,
there's something I like to say maybe in
closing about courage.
People say that to me and you know,
I don't think it's exactly right.
There's A.
There's a line in the old testament.
The fear of God is the beginning of
wisdom and I think it's more like that.
It's not that I'm courageous,
it's that I'm afraid of the right
things.
So when I made my videos,
it wasn't like that didn't make me
nervous,
but I was less nervous about going back
to bed and not saying what I had to say
that I was about making the videos
because I know where this is going,
I don't want to go there.
And so it's not so much courage.
It's that it's a matter of uh,
it's,
it's less risky to say something than to
remain silent when you know,
there's something to be said.
I know that to be the case.
And so lots of times in life it's like
there's no pathway forward that's going
to shield you from risk.
You get to pick this risk or you get to
pick this risk.
And I think I picked the lesser risk and
that might be wise,
but I'm not so sure it's courageous.
Well,
I think it's admirable.
Let's leave it on that basis.
Alright,
thank you.
Thank you very much for the
conversation.